working at the scp foundation can really
get your appetite going after spending a
rough shift monitoring the acid levels
in scp-682's tank or performing the
rituals necessary to keep the devourer
of worlds on the other side of scp-2317
sometimes you just need a quick snack to
hold you over before you return to the
old grind problem is that the scp
foundation even the break room can be
perilous dr dan is notorious for
pilfering pudding cups from the communal
fridge and ever since the administrator
himself stole your tuna sandwich you
just don't feel safe spending your lunch
break on site anymore but this presents
its own series of issues you only have
an hour for lunch and obviously you
can't order in due to security issues
also if you're eating off-site you have
even less time to finish your lunch
because the site you're currently
stationed at is relatively remote we're
talking at least a half hour round trip
to actually get to somewhere so you're
gonna need your food fast and when it
comes to fast food few eateries are as
prolific as the golden arches mcdonald's
and just to clarify this video is not
sponsored we're gonna tell you about a
horrifying anomalous secret that this
company really doesn't want you to know
about let's not think about that just
yet though your stomach is rumbling and
you need that quarter pounder so bad
that even being trapped in the red
reality with dr scranton couldn't stop
you from getting it when you finally
arrive you buy your typical order a
quarter pounder with french fries a
coffee and a mcflurry you see dr clef a
few tables down enjoying a box of
chicken nuggets and ketchup but decide
not to engage as you sit and enjoy your
meager little lunch knowing you'll
probably be coordinating the cleaning
efforts of scp-173's containment chamber
by the end of the day your eyes drift
over to something even more unsettling
happy the current mascot for mcdonald's
happy meals you can't help but shudder
you've seen some pretty horrific things
on the job nightmarish things you fear
no monster but that thing it scares you
those big soulless eyes the wide gaping
maw full of two white teeth hits
diabolical sneakers no child should ever
have to look at that you can't help but
wonder whatever happened to ronald
mcdonald the hamburger happy clown that
shield fast food to you throughout your
childhood what is he up to now well we
have an answer for you but i'll warn you
you may not be quite as eager to suck
down a big mac on a diet coke after
hearing this ronald mcdonald first
introduced says the company's mascot in
1963 had a pretty good run before
finally being largely phased out by the
company in the mid-2010s for a greater
focus on the nasty little box homunculus
you can thank john wayne gacy pennywise
and those goofballs dressed up as clowns
back in 2016 for that but like anyone
who loses favor stateside ronald had a
prosperous career ahead of him outside
the country well not the ronald we know
at least you see in an undisclosed
cattle farm in 2004 most likely in north
america a monster was born a horrific
abomination birthed from a cow like many
have theorized about scp-058 the heart
of darkness but this nasty little
creature wasn't a giant heart with a
stinger and scorpion legs in many ways
it appeared superficially humanoid save
for its stark white skin its thick red
lips and its full head of bright frizzy
red hair but that was only the start of
the unnerving strangeness exhibited by
this miracle child it was born with
white gloves and long clownish shoes
seemingly grafted to its feet fresh from
birth the creature was huge with a
disportionately large head and wide
disgusting pores that seemed to
perpetually leak fry oil the creature
was unresponsive to any kind of external
stimuli perhaps suggesting it was brain
dead and it remained completely dormant
most of the time while most people would
have screamed run away or call the
police the farmers at this particular
cattle farm decided to let it ride and
see how this whole nightmarish affair
played out that sense of curiosity and
patience would soon pay off for them
financially it didn't take long for the
creature to grow the bigger it got the
more it looked like a giant mutant
version of mcdonald's iconic mascot
ronald mcdonald and this wasn't just a
coincidence either it turned out that
this monster was somehow intrinsically
linked to the mcdonald's brand because
once a day the creature would
horrifically unhinge its jaw and begin
to barf out a huge quantity of
mcdonald's food and we're not talking
about raw materials that are converted
into mcdonald's food the creature later
dubbed scp-5962
vomited out fully packaged mcdonald's
products the owners of this clownish
monster had just hit the lottery so to
speak while the particulars of the deal
are unclear they somehow contacted a
representative of the mcdonald's
corporation based in china
in exchange for presumably a large sum
of money chinese mcdonald's operatives
covertly entered the country and
shepherded the now massive creature over
to a mcdonald's owned warehouse in
beijing by this point it was around 4
meters tall and weighed over 5 tons it
was kept inside a cage and housed at
some cost but soon enough the creature
was paying for itself as we mentioned
before the creature constantly secreted
fry oil which was siphoned off for use
in preparing mcdonald's food across the
country the huge quantity of packaged
food that it vomited out every day was
also shipped off to restaurants across
the country making the chinese branch of
mcdonald's incredibly financially
successful they were able to make an
almost complete profit on all of these
foods and drinks once transport costs
were subtracted of course
scp-5962 had become mcdonald's china's
best-kept secret but of course no secret
this sensational could stay under wraps
forever no matter how much people in the
warehouse were paid or threatened for
their silence if your day job was
siphoning grease off of a giant mutant
clown for the purpose of preparing
mcdonald's food across the country
there'd be no way you wouldn't speak to
somebody about it nobody knows whose
loose lips sunk this incredibly
profitable ship but rumors began to
spread around beijing about a huge clown
inside of a mcdonald's packaging
facility that was when local field
agents of the scp foundation finally
took notice two agents jonathan zhang
and george nagosa were dispatched to
perform an infiltration mission along
with a team of backup personnel they
entered the warehouse apprehending any
employees they found as they and their
reinforcements reached the northern side
of the facility they found
scp-5962 with a heavy collar around its
neck chained to the ground like king
kong as mcdonald's employees wheeled
away carts of packaged food neither of
the attending agents were fans of
mcdonald's food but even then just
seeing this horrible display was enough
to make them feel nauseous the creature
was taken and contained by the scp
foundation who conducted a number of
tests on it they found that the monster
had no real internal organs saved for 27
interconnected stomachs genetically they
also found that the creature was far
more cow than human the same could sadly
not be said for the food that
scp-5962 was vomiting out seriously if
you were already feeling a little queasy
from all this we need to warn you that
this is the part where things get really
vile let's talk about what the
mcdonald's food barfed up by
scp-5962 was actually made out of as we
mentioned earlier the food exuded by the
creature was genetically human with dna
often matching that of people who are
alive and in no way affected by this
anomalous process tests have indicated
that certain foods condiments and
beverages correspond to more specific
types of bodily tissue and liquid for
example the bacon and fries were shown
to be cartilage and ligaments the bread
turned out to be made from hair nails
and skin the coffee was liquefied fecal
matter the chicken nuggets were made
from fingers ovaries and testes even the
water was a mix of saline and sweat and
of course the ice cream was comprised of
pus bone marrow feces and nasal mucus
depending on the flavor you get the idea
we'll stop listing off examples before
you lose your lunch but rest assured all
of the food produced by
scp-5962 was made of human organic
matter when the scp foundation
interviewed mr chen the manager of the
facility where
scp-5962 was being held before his
amnesic treatment he seemed incredibly
casual about the whole thing as far as
he was concerned the food still tasted
exactly the same as regular mcdonald's
food and it didn't appear to have any
adverse health effects beyond what you
could expect from regular non-anomalous
fast food it's actually less cruel and
disturbing than the slaughterhouses
where the meat is typically obtained mr
chen also contested that
scp-5962 wasn't all that dangerous
either the only time it ever performed
at offensive action was when an employee
of the enemy fast food franchise burger
king entered its vicinity the creature
vomited a stream of hot coffee at the
corporate interloper like a fire hose
until he left suggesting that it does
have some kind of strange inherent
loyalty to the mcdonald's company but
still other than this isolated incident
the creature has never even displayed
sentience it was a big strange clownish
mcdonald's food dispenser when
questioned about the origins of scp-5962
mr chen once again underplayed the
strangeness of the situation saying that
he'd heard rumors the farm that sold him
scp-5962 and also sold other strange
anomalous creatures to eager buyers in
the u.s the farm which we can only
assume is situated right next to a
radioactive waste dump was also behind
scp-4158
also known as big charlie this giant
omnivorous and seemingly immortal mutant
cow is believed to have been birthed
from a non-anomalous cow sold to the
butcher's block slaughterhouse it looked
hideous and seemed to suffer from a wide
variety of health issues leading to the
employees at the slaughterhouse trying
to put the creature out of its misery
however no matter how hard they tried to
kill the monster it just wouldn't die
its bones were pretty much
indestructible and no matter how much of
its flesh was cut off it just kept
growing back causing no ill effects to
the creature itself eventually the
slaughterhouse workers tried cooking and
eating the meat leading to them
discovering it tasted just as good as
non-anomalous meat much like the chinese
mcdonald's and scp-5962
the workers had just hit the lottery
with big charlie as long as they kept
feeding the monster which ate everything
from bricks to other non-anomalous cows
it provided a pretty much limitless
supply of meat giving them unprecedented
economic prosperity in other words big
charlie was a literal cash cow jeff fein
the slaughterhouse director even started
worshiping big charlie as a kind of
demigod by drinking his blood he
believed that big charlie was a savior
sent to lift them all out of their
struggle and desperation sadly for them
the stp foundation sent them right back
when big charlie escaped their
slaughterhouse and foundation field
agents found secured and contained it it
was a sad day for the butcher's block so
what have we learned today whether
you're in the u.s of a or the chinese
heartland if you're chowing down on fast
food you really have no idea where it
came from i mean we kind of knew that
already but for all we know the food
you're enjoying could have just been
vomited up by a giant fat clown or cut
from the flesh of a mutated cow just
think about that next time you're
enjoying a burger but hey let's be
honest with ourselves we'll all probably
still eat it now go check out
scp-3166 monster garfield attack
gorfield and killer living graffiti
scp-1155 predatory street art for more
strange threats from the scp foundation